[Música]
como es posible que alguien pueda
dibujar durante todos los días de los
últimos 13 años que hay detrás como
podéis vosotros hacer algo todos los
días sin que sea vuestra nuestro trabajo
ni vuestra obligación ni os paguen por
ello
yo hace 13 años estaba 92 kilos
y unos amigos me dijeron no eres capaz
de bajar 20 kilos en un año y obviamente
eran kilos que me sobraban y yo les dije
que sí
abrir una página web con el nombre de el
objetivo que era 72 kilos y ahí iba
subiendo una viñeta al día durante
durante todo el tiempo que yo pudiera no
y esta fue la primera viñeta el primer
dibujo era muy básico muy sencillo
incluso me dibuje 66 dedos en el pie
derecho
imaginaos loving que dibujaba
y era un proyecto de ilustración que yo
había comenzado en mis ratos libres
mientras yo trabajaba en una agencia de
publicidad pero qué diferencia había
entre ese proyecto de ilustración y
otros proyectos de ilustración que ya
había comenzado y que de alguna manera
se habían quedado muertos en el camino y
yo había perdido la ilusión por
seguirlos como estos dos marcianos que
venían a la tierra a conquistarla o
estos dos astronautas que se enamoran
van a miles de años luz el uno de la
otra que había detrás qué diferencia
tenía 72 kilos con esto bueno pues
cuando empecé a
a dibujar en los primeros días de aquel
enero de 2008
empecé a ver que el objetivo de llegar a
72 kilos no era lo que me estaba
moviendo a seguir dibujando todos los
días ni siquiera el hecho de dibujar que
me apasionaba y empezaba a descubrir
cosas de mí de mi grafía de mis letras
de cómo me dibujaba a mí mismo
lo que me estaba moviendo el motor de
todo eso era ganarles a mis amigos yo lo
que hice que luego lo he descubierto es
hacerme la figura de los archienemigos
que tenían la misma forma y vestían
igual y hablaban igual que mis amigos
pero los consideraba archienemigos ellos
no se dieron cuenta de todo en todo ese
sueño que ese año que duró la apuesta
pero me hicieron un favor increíble
porque me estaban ayudando día a día a
intentar dibujar y subir a mi página web
un dibujo
el problema vino cuando termino ese año
y llegué a los 72 kilos y gane la
apuesta y les gané a mis archienemigos
pero es que me quedé sin tema
me quedé sin enemigos porque ya había
llegado los 72 kilos que iba a hacer
entonces entonces decidí buscarme otro
tema que fue correr me encantaba correr
pero también si alguna vez habéis
intentado correr hoy empiezo a correr
el problema es que si no tenéis un
objetivo lo dejáis al de un mes o al de
una semana no sabéis si correr un día 25
a la semana y desmotiva es muy
fácilmente entonces yo me propuse algo
yo ya venía corriendo siempre me había
gustado correr hacia el ejercicio de
hacer deporte entonces me propuse tener
otro archienemigo y en este caso fue la
maratón de tokio una maratón que es una
distancia bastante compleja para alguien
que no había corrido durante no había
corrido esas distancias y un lugar que
me apetecía mucho ir pero que estaba
lejos que no era la maratón de mi ciudad
y eso me motivaba y yo dentro de mi
cabeza ese archienemigo era el que
siempre tenía que rendir y luchar todos
los días iba dibujando un dibujito sobre
esto que me estaba pasando de correr lo
mucho o poco que entrenaba las ganas que
tenía las cosas que me decían mis amigos
mi familia
entonces después de la maratón de tokio
corrí y me encantó el tiempo daba igual
yo no no pretendía ser el mejor corredor
del mundo yo pretendía llegar a la línea
de salida y terminar llegar a la línea
de meta después de esa maratón vino la
maratón de amsterdam otra vez la maratón
de tokio la maratón de roma la maratón
de sevilla en fin
una distancia que me gustaba y que me
servía como enemigo al que batir
entonces luego dije quizá este esquema
de buscar enemigos se puede aplicar a
otras cosas de mi vida
y en ese momento yo estaba viviendo en
madrid
y he estado trabajando en una empresa
multinacional en la que estaba muy bien
pero no estaba en el lugar correcto
yo quería vivir en bilbao que era donde
estaba viviendo mi novia y dije por qué
no hago este esquema de
del archienemigo y dibujo a madrid como
mi gran el gran villano al que tengo que
batir empecé a cometer esta temática en
mis dibujos en salir de la zona de
confort en intentar superarme en
intentar valorar lo que tenía cerca de
mi familia y mi novia y empezar a
construir hacia ese lugar hacia ese
lugar
y funcionó y poco a poco intente salir
de ahí y llegar a bilbao y empezar una
vida en bilbao y cuando llegué a bilbao
me pasa una cosa muy curiosa que un
compañero del trabajo me dijo oye oscar
sabes que he visto tus dibujos
este chico veía los dibujos que yo subía
a internet a mí a internet y me dijo
sabes qué
últimamente he visto que estás dibujando
con acuarelas y no son muy buenos los
dibujos
entonces yo le dije puede que tenga
razón no soy muy bueno pero
me vio hay una pista y dije me fui a
casa y dije aquí tengo otro archienemigo
gente como el que da igual cómo sea alto
bajo pero está pensando que tiene en su
cabeza para decirle a una persona que no
conoce tanto que no es bueno en algo
porque hay gente así en el mundo
entonces me fui a casa y dibuje esta
misma viñeta pero en vez de dibujar
sobre el tema de la acuarela cambió un
poco los personajes y dibuje a pianistas
y ahí estáis viendo tienes que dejarlo
no eres bueno y la otra persona dice si
lo dejo nunca será bueno y creo que este
es el esquema de de cómo funciona el
superpoder de hacer un poco todos los
días igual estaréis pensando que estoy
dando una imagen errónea de todo esto
porque no todo el mundo que practica
todos los días se convierte en bueno o
se convierte en el mejor no
efectivamente tenéis razón yo no estoy
diciendo que todo el mundo va a jugar en
la nba o va a ser el mejor trompetista
del mundo yo digo que si se practica se
va a ser un poquito mejor que que el día
que empezaste
y en toda esta aventura nacieron mis
hijos y ahí me di cuenta que igual la
estrategia de buscarme un archienemigo
no era la correcta igual habría que
girar 180 grados y empezar a construir y
abrir a mirar cosas que merecían la pena
ser contadas lugares que merecían la
pena ser visitados personas que merecían
la pena ser conocidas sabores músicas
libros y todo eso intentar contárselo a
mis hijos para cuando ellos pudieran
leer cuando puedan leer dentro de dos
tres cuatro años lo puedan conocer de mi
parte a través de un libro y a través de
mis dibujos y ese es el motor que me
está llevando ahora mismo a hacer todo
lo que estoy haciendo y son viñetas
diarias que son que me llevan unas 23
horas al día pero que merece la pena
porque estoy construyendo para eso ya no
tengo archienemigos ya creo que no tengo
archienemigos alguna vez alguno se
acerca pero intento construir para mis
hijos
el superpoder de hacer un poco todos los
días tiene una ventaja que se
retroalimenta que cuando construyes un
día tras otro tras otro tras otro y das
un par de pasos para atrás y ves tu
primera viñeta y una vez tú la viñeta
que publicaste ayer o la que vas a
publicar esta noche te das cuenta de
toda esa evolución quizá igual estáis
viendo y diréis bueno no eres un gran
dibujante efectivamente pero yo no
espero que nadie valore mi trabajo lo
valoro yo es el juez aquí estoy yo
y yo creo que hay una evolución bastante
buena entre la primera y la última por
eso cualquier proyecto en el que estéis
cualquier retoque que os queráis hacer
yo os recomiendo que es una herramienta
muy buena para para saber para qué os
apoye es que llevéis un archivo de todo
lo que hacéis desde el primer día que
empecé estéis a tocar el piano que os
grave es un pequeño vídeo y que lo
vayáis grabando si podéis todos los días
mejor para que el día que os venga el
bajón el día que os venga alguien y os
diga que no sois tan buenos vayáis a
vuestra casa veáis vuestro archivo y
veis la primera viñeta el primer el
primer el primer día que toca estéis el
piano tocasteis la trompeta o os
pusisteis en vuestros primeros apuntes
el primer día de la uni y veis los
últimos y veáis una evolución siempre
hay una evolución y casi siempre es
buena y eso es un superpoder que se
retroalimenta
a mí siempre me gusta pensar que todo
esto es como un fuego los levantes por
la mañana si hay un fuego pequeñito no
muy grande es un fuego que podéis apagar
y vuestro cometido en ese día es
apagarlo sea como sea pase lo que pase a
veces podréis soplar y apagarlo a veces
podréis pisar y apagarlo no os pasa nada
lo vais a poder apagar y si no lo apagas
en el día os que máis y si os que máis
ya no sois vosotros ya no tiene sentido
y lo bueno de apagarlo ya digo que es un
fuego muy pequeño
si lo pagáis al día siguiente vais a
tener otro fuego que apagar y después
otro y después otro imaginaos que dentro
de siete diez veinte días un mes quince
de quince meses lo que lo que queráis os
vais a convertir
expertos apagando fuegos y quizá venga
gente y os pregunte cómo apagar fuegos
también y podréis contárselo y sabréis
de temperatura de agua de fuego de un
montón de cosas que al principio no
estabais pensando que podríais hacer o
dicho de otra manera
todo este jardín que habéis montado
desde el primer día que no había nada y
empieza estéis a sembrar a regar a
cuidar vuestro jardín
llegará un momento que vuestro jardín
sea tan exuberante que os costará pensar
que antes no había nada
yo a mí me cuesta pensar que hace 13
años no había nada nada no había ningún
cuaderno rellenado había algún dibujo de
marcianos o de astronautas que se
enamoraban pero todo esto que esté que
he creado no había nada y esto me anima
a pensar ya seguir haciendo cosas día a
día
este superpoder lo que te permite
también es aplicarlo a otras otras
facetas de la vida aprender idiomas
aprender deportes a practicar cosas que
antes no sabías hay que afrontarlo desde
la expresión más mínima no pretendas
competir en los juegos olímpicos quizá
eso sea un reto muy muy muy grande y un
archienemigo al que batir pero empezar
de más abajo de una cosa más sencilla
cuanto más sencillo cuanto más pequeño
sea el fuego que a pagar todos los días
más lejos vais a llegar
y hablando de llegar lejos uno de los
problemas que siempre aparecen
es la gente que se os va a acercar y os
va a decir que no vais a llegar lejos la
gente que os va a decir que ya está
hecho lo que habéis es lo que estáis
haciendo la gente que os va a decir que
os diga que no merece la pena ese camino
que estáis iniciando a esa gente yo
tengo una estrategia
qué es
dibujarles una puerta meta metafórica
invitarles a que sepa que pasan es una
puerta que es de ida todo lo que el que
pase por ahí no vuelve
y os va a liberar y os va a dejar el
camino más fácil porque lo que
necesitamos aquí es gente con ilusión
vosotros tenéis que cargarlos de ilusión
para hacer para empezar todos los
proyectos que tengáis merece la pena
mucho de ese viaje y os vais encontrar
un montón de problemas y un montón de
soluciones
cualquier proyecto que tenga es que
seguro que estáis ahí diciendo vale esto
que me estás contando
yo tengo una cosa y que quiero iniciar y
no sé cómo
hay una pregunta y una respuesta que
siempre
me sirve a mí para seguir avanzando
va a funcionar
y la respuesta siempre es sí remas sí
y os animo
a que tengáis un reto aquí os pongáis un
camino para avanzar porque el superpoder
de hacer un poco todos los días
tiene poco de super
un poco de poder solo tiene sólo tenéis
que hacer un poco todos los días muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
no